[Music]
straight ahead on lawn crime daily
i wish every single day that this was a
nightmare
that i could just wake up from heartfelt
victim impact statements are presented
in the parkland school shooter penalty
phase trial and dante wright's
girlfriend files suit against kim potter
for emotional and physical damage
have you had
long-term impacts from that broken jaw
or the injuries that you suffered
plus kristen smart's college roommate
takes the stand as a former classmate
and his father are tried for her murder
but first how are you feeling today alex
i actually feel good because i get a
chance to for the first time
say what's really going on instead of
the corporate media and high-powered law
firms manipulating what i actually did
conspiracy theory broadcaster alex jones
takes the stand in the sandy hook
defamation civil trial lawn crime daily
covering court cases from coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everybody to long crime daily
i'm jesse weber in for brian buckmeyer
the defense rests shortly after infowars
host and conspiracy theory broadcaster
alex jones takes the stand in his own
defense in the sandy hook civil trial in
texas as the only defense witness in
2012 a gunman entered the connecticut
elementary school and killed 20 first
grade students and six staff members
after the shooting jones said on his
infowars show that he believed it was
all a hoax and staged with government
actors in order to push gun control
though he later said he believed the
shooting did happen he claims he had a
constitutional right to say it didn't
the families of the sandy hook shooting
victims sued the political conspiracy
theorist over his comments courts in
both texas and connecticut found jones
liable for defamation entering default
judgments against him saying he ignored
several court orders and failed to
respond to discovery demands juries will
now determine what he will pay in
damages this first trial out in texas
stems from the lawsuit filed by neil
heslin and scarlett lewis the parents of
six-year-old victim jesse lewis they
both testified this week to the impact
of jones comments and how they're still
impacted now a decade later jones took
the stand as the only defense witness
tuesday and wednesday during
cross-examination jones was asked about
his comments about the shooting and
other incidents being fake
i'm talking boston bombing you've been
telling the world fake not real a
department of homeland security drill
right
there was a drill i think real people
got
bombed but we've we've asked questions
on both sides yeah you've said the exact
opposite
you've in fact said that some of those
people who were claimed to be injured
were crisis actors in other tragedies
just like in san diego you said they
reported on other people saying that
and in fact you've said about some of
the people at sandy hook
during your coverage of sandy hook you
have said they were actually some of the
people pretending to be injured in the
boston bombing you said that i don't
remember that okay you remember the
shooting in parkland florida in 2018 yes
and you called a bunch of people crisis
actors there you said crisis actors were
used from parkland florida no i didn't
i said they had the
the film
the the drama club then go do interviews
about it because they had skills to to
present themselves do you remember
saying that parkland was a false flag
engineered to start a civil war i said
it could i mean i believe it could be
you would agree with me
that every
single mass tragedy mass shooting mass
bombing that you can recall right now in
the past 15 years you have attached the
words false flag to it yes or no
no
at the end of the day tuesday there were
some pretty tense moments with the judge
and also after she left the bench
you may not say to this jury
that you complied with discovery
that is not true
you may not say it again
you may not tell this jury that you are
bankrupt that is also
not true i believe what i said was true
so yes you believe everything you say is
true but it isn't your beliefs do not
make something true
and that he's slow
i'm slowing up
them fake videos anymore
that's what you're trying to shut my
mouth you'll never succeed
oh boy joining us today co-host terry
austin and trial attorney bernard v
alona it's great to have you both here
bernard i'll start with you the judge
said that jones wasn't telling the truth
under oath big no no so could he be held
in contempt of court
jesse alex jones can i say liar liar
pants on fire
but unfortunately as you can see judge
gamble is not playing with either party
but especially with alex jones now will
there be charges in terms of contempt of
court i highly doubt it if anything if
the judge were to believe that alex
jones is lying you would need a district
attorney's office to be willing to
prosecute him on perjury charges but in
terms of contempt charges i don't see it
for lying under oath however the the
attorneys can be held responsible in
terms of contempt of court if they're
not following with the demands or the
requests that were made so for example
judge gamble said look you cannot say
that you comply with discovery obviously
because it did not happen right so if
that were to happen in terms of the
attorney saying that then the judge can
hold the attorney in terms of content
but i don't see that with alex jones yet
but you never know what's going to
happen so terry you know joan during
jones cross-examination the plaintiff's
counsel asked if he was aware that his
attorney accidentally sent all of his
text messages to him how do you think
that's going to affect the case
oh what a tangle when we weave when we
first practice to deceive it will affect
the case the jury heard all of that
don't claim that he didn't have any text
he said he looked through all of his
texts there was nothing on sandy hook on
the shooting or anything he basically
said at his deposition that i have
nothing to give you as it turns out his
own attorney accidentally sent it to the
plaintiff's attorney and frankly all of
the jury is going to get to see that and
hear that so i think it's uh something
that's going to hurt his case yeah alex
jones maybe not being that truthful
that's something that the jury is going
to have to consider all right we'll keep
following it but we want to head north
right now to illinois where the man
accused of committing the highland park
mass shooting enters a not guilty plea
on all counts just last week the suspect
was indicted on 117 counts for opening
fire during a fourth of july parade
seven people were killed and dozens more
injured officials say the gunman planned
the attack for weeks and possibly months
leading up to the massacre on wednesday
the 21 year old pleaded not guilty to
all charges including 21 counts of first
degree murder 48 counts of attempted
murder and 48 counts of aggravated
battery with a firearm the suspect is
due back in court on november 1st for a
case management conference
and still ahead on long crime daily the
girlfriend of dante wright files suit
against kim potter and the city she
wants police for but first a california
father and son stand trial in the death
of kristen smart what smart's former
roommate has to say as she takes the
stand
[Music]
and welcome back everybody heading to
california as week three of testimony is
underway for the murder trial of paul
and ruben flores as a friend of the
victim tells jurors one defendant seemed
to have a strange interest in her before
her disappearance the father and son are
charged in connection with the
disappearance and death of kristen smart
26 years ago the son paul is charged
with her murder and prosecutors allege
rubin helped cover up the college
student's death by burying her body in
his backyard before moving her friends
of christian smart say the younger flora
seemed to have an unusual interest in
the cal poly student before she went
missing after leaving an off-campus
party around memorial day in 1996
investigators say paul was the last
person seen with smart her friend steven
fleming testified this week that she
seemed uncomfortable when paul was
around and that he was often spotted
alone outside of smart's dorm late at
night even though he didn't live there
prosecutors believe paul raped and
killed smart after allegedly
volunteering to walk her back to her
dorm after the party but she was never
seen again
terry this is a sad case and smart
disappeared in 1996 making this case
more than two decades old
i'm wondering if that could cause any
issues here
it's definitely going to cause some real
issues it's tragic that these cases go
unsolved for so long especially when it
involves someone who has disappeared and
then of course they find that she died
the number one issue is going to be
witness testimony memories fade after
such a long time and literally some of
the witnesses may have passed away then
there's the issue of the forensic
evidence there may be evidence that was
never collected or even if it had been
collected it may be lost at this point
and then the other issue i think is
getting the authorities to be committed
to get the resources involved in
following up and making sure they have
all of the evidence to actually try a
case like this because it will take a
great deal of evidence bernardo smart's
body has never been found does that mean
it's more difficult for the prosecution
to successfully win
absolutely jesse as a former homicide
prosecutor i can tell you this when
you're dealing with a cold case a
homicide from 1996 when times were
different in the sense of you didn't
have social media you didn't have the
technology that you have now where you
can track a person even though you don't
find a body makes it much more difficult
because it was so in the past in 1996
especially when you're thinking what
they say nobody no case because we don't
know what she died from you lose the
forensic evidence in regards to her body
and we don't have a cause of death and
there's always that piece of doubt that
a juror may have that look she may still
be alive or living a separate life
somewhere else under a different
identity but we've also covered cases
where a jury comes back and convicts
even without a body so we'll see which
way this shakes out move over to florida
now where officers make an eviction
notice mishap long crime network sierra
gillespie has a story
hello
what are you doing uh we're here to
finalize the eviction
it was posted a week ago an eviction
notice served at the wrong home what is
your name
my name
is jennifer what's your last name
jennifer jennifer michelle's ring
doorbell camera captured the incident
when pasco county florida officers
attempted to serve her an eviction
notice
i am caught up on my vote nobody has
served me an eviction notice the problem
officers were at the wrong house what
the hell was going on through rings live
video feature michelle spoke to officers
as they worked to disable her front
door's lock what is your name
and that is my house jennifer what's
your last name jennifer after telling
them her name officers realized they
were at the wrong house
that's when officers admitted they had
the wrong address hey we actually we do
apologize
we have the wrong house it's the next
door neighbors what we're going to have
to do is we're going to have to they're
going to have to repair their locks
the pasco county sheriff's office says
the incident was a mistake and is now
under investigation reporting for long
crime network i'm sierra gillespie
yikes all right coming up on long crime
daily emotions running high as victim
impact statements are presented in the
parkland school shooter penalty phase
trial plus the passenger in dante
wright's vehicle seeks damages from the
city where he was killed
welcome back everybody the woman who was
seated next to dante wright when he was
shot and killed is now suing ex-officer
kim potter and the city where she worked
alana albrecht payton now seeks 150 000
in damages for the injuries she suffered
during the incident the lawsuit also
says that she suffers ptsd from watching
wright die in front of her albrecht
payton says she and dante wright were in
the early stages of dating when he was
pulled over for a traffic violation in
april 21 2021. ex-officer kim potter
later shot wright claiming she mistook
her gun for a taser potter was
ultimately convicted in connection to
wright's death last year and is
currently serving a two-year prison
sentence albrecht payton testified in
december of last year outlining the
injuries she suffered when wright's
vehicle crashed after the shooting
i had a lacerated lip so
i had a scar
i had stitches it went all the way
through
i don't know what happened but the whole
way through my lip um
stitches in my ear and a fracture jaw
i had wires on my jaw for about
six weeks maybe a little more
and i
sustained them like with discussion
so bernard here's something interesting
dante wright's family reached a more
than three million dollar settlement
with brooklyn center earlier this year
so could all brick payton receive the
same kind of payout a similar payout
anything like that
so jesse i don't think that she's going
to receive a similar payout of 3.2
million dollars as dante wright's family
got and several reasons because there
are several factors that play into
whether acacia settle number one she
didn't die unfortunately she was
involved in that horrible accident in
which she actually saw dante wright get
killed in front of her and it is so
clear that she's traumatized by because
look at when she's testifying a year
after dante wright being killed and
she's still so emotionally disturbed by
it so taking into account that she
didn't die and that she had a broken jaw
and also that ken potter wasn't charged
with anything relating to her the
settlement if there is a settlement is
going to be much much lower than the 3.2
million but terry let's just assume the
suit is not settled okay do you think
she's got a good chance of prevailing
with this
she has an excellent chance of
prevailing listen she sued both the city
and kim potter and that was a smart move
kim potter he sued for negligence in
shooting into that car and risking the
life of everyone around kim potter and
she sued the city because that's the
deep pockets he only asked for 150 000
in damages which i think is quite
reasonable because she has gone through
quite a bit of both physical and
emotional distress she's been diagnosed
with ptsd
acute and post-traumatic stress disorder
depression anxiety
and you can tell from her testimony i
agree that she definitely is still
suffering both physically and
emotionally from that traumatic event
and no one helped her they put her in
handcuffs back so i think she should
have brought a suit as you're seeing the
ripple effects from that event still
coming about
when we come back the parkland school
shooter penalty phase trial parents give
heartfelt victim impact statements that
seem to affect a defense attorney
and welcome back emotional reactions
from family members friends and even a
defense attorney as victim impact
statements are presented in the parkland
school shooter penalty phase trial last
year the gunman pleaded guilty to 17
counts of murder and 17 counts of
attempted murder for the deadly marjory
stoneman douglas high school shooting in
2018. it's now up to a broward county
jury to decide whether the defendant
receives life in prison or the death
penalty throughout the trial we've seen
emotional responses from the parents in
the gallery including max schachter
whose son alex died in the shooting on
wednesday he addressed the jury
four and a half years ago
alex was just a ninth grader sitting in
his english class at marjory stoneman
douglas high school on valentine's day
a day that should have been filled with
candy hearts balloons and love
it was the last day we would see
our sweet little boy alex
the last day we would hug alex
the last day we would kiss alex
our family is broken
there is this constant emptiness
i feel i can't truly be happy
if i smile
i know that behind that smile is the
sharp realization
that part of me will always be sad and
miserable
because alex isn't here
and jurors also heard from the mother of
jamie guttenberg this week who described
how her daughter's murder affected her
teenage son
our son jesse was 17 a junior at marjory
stoneman douglas high school when
jamie's life was taken
at the end of every school day he would
meet jamie just a freshman near her last
class and they would walk together to
his car so he could drive her home
this particular day it would have been
at the 1200 building
but he didn't get the chance
after the tragedy jesse eventually made
the painful decision to go back to the
school where it all happened
every day
during his senior year he parked his car
and walked past the 1200 building
his first period class that year was
right across from the building
he struggles immensely with survivor's
guilt why he made it out that day and
jamie didn't
he beats himself up inside for not being
able to save her even though it wasn't
possible he fears losing his family
and he is not the same upbeat and happy
person and feels he'll never be the same
bernarda these victim impact statements
are incredibly hard to hear they're very
emotional for many people reading or
listening and even one of the
defendant's own defense attorneys was
seen crying two days in a row i have to
ask is that appropriate behavior for a
defense attorney i mean she is human
well the last part jessie about it is
that she is human and we all are human i
don't think there's anyone except
nicholas cruz who has not who has not
been affected emotionally by listening
to the testimony doing this death
penalty phase of this trial you got to
think for that attorney as well as the
jurors they're impacted not just by what
is being said by the witness and the
witness stand but also the family of the
loved ones that are sitting in the
courtroom as well so they're getting it
more than we are since we're seeing it
from our homes or our offices so
unfortunately we can pick and choose
what we want to see but for those jurors
those attorneys they're watching every
second of it i will say this if it were
the prosecutor that were crying and i
with the defense attorney i will bring
it up to the judge and ask for a
mistrial but because it's a defense
attorney i don't think it's going to be
an issue because they'll spin it and say
i acknowledge that he was wrong and that
we're all human right right
terry 17 people were killed that day
each one has you know their own story
is there one account that's maybe
impacted you the most
well you know you're right they all have
their own stories and all of those
stories are important and they should be
heard and the pain of any of the family
members is just unthinkable but the
testimony of the gutenberg's to me was
particularly difficult to hear mr
gutenberg actually said he and the
family was running late that morning and
he said he was rushing them and he told
them you gotta go you gotta go you're
gonna be late and that was the last
thing he ever said to them and then
hearing from mrs gutenberg she basically
said that her son now has this guilt
issue about leaving his sister and the
father was the one who said go don't go
back in run and now they have a
difficult relationship so
i think all in all it's very hard to
hear the testimony that goes in that
kind of fashion where they all have such
a hard time now getting along and having
vacations together you're hoping it
brings some sense of closure to the
families at the very least
terry bernarda thank you so much
everyone out there thanks for joining us
here on law and crime daily we'll see
you next time as we discuss justice in
america
[Music]
[Music]
you